les quiero contar la historia de una
mujer extraordinaria
su nombre es in rome tea y ella es
actualmente la presidenta y directora
general de ibm una de las mujeres una de
las empresas en tecnología más grandes
del mundo tiene además es una mujer con
mucha influencia en el mundo de los
negocios pero para que llegara ahí tuvo
que pasar por 30 años en la escalera
corporativa probar todos sus talentos y
por diversas unidades de negocios hasta
ocupar la posición que ocupa hoy
desde afuera podríamos pensar que la
historia de gini no es muy diferente a
la de otros hombres y otras mujeres que
han optado por la carrera corporativa
sin embargo cuando hacemos doble clic en
la historia del de gini nos damos cuenta
de que para una mujer nacida en los 50s
hija de inmigrantes italianos
y de clase media era muy poco probable
que ella llegara hasta donde llegó
para cheney
el mundo de la tecnología le abrió una
nueva posibilidad en 1979 el año en el
cual ella ingresó a la universidad
apenas un 12% de las mujeres en eeuu
tenían acceso a un título universitario
versus el 20 por ciento de los hombres
pares de ellas
apenas nueve de cada 100 estudiantes de
las ciencias en tecnología que ella
estudió como carrera
era compuesto por mujeres
en 1981 esta desproporción persiguió a
jim y fue el año en el cual ingresó a
ibm y también el año donde la compañía
lanzó la primera computadora personal
miremos esta imagen con detalle esta
imagen fue la primera publicidad del
modelo famosísimo de ibm 5150 que
popularizó y catapultó a la computadora
personal pero también llevó un mensaje
super claro la computadora personal y yo
ya sé yo es un hombre
eso colocó a los hombres a la cabeza de
la revolución tecnológica en los
ochentas y noventas empezamos a ver más
publicidad que los colocaban en el
centro como los beneficiarios de esta
tecnología las caras de steve jobs y de
bill gates se popularizaron en las
revistas más famosas posicionando a los
hombres y sus caras como los principales
encabezados de la revolución tecnológica
para quienes crecimos en los 80s y 90s
esta historia no es muy extraña yo
recuerdo muy bien que cuando era pequeña
y no contábamos con computadoras
personales en mi casa ni con videojuegos
ni consolas
nuestro para mi hermana y para mi
nuestro momento de mayor emoción era ir
a casa de mi primo donde si se contaban
con estas herramientas y de hecho nos
disfrutamos muchísimo quedarnos por
horas jugando con la computadora cuando
mi madre nos decía ya paren ya paren hay
que regresar a casa
para mi hermana y para mí fue un nuevo
mundo al que se nos abrió pero no fue lo
mismo para muchas niñas más de hecho un
estudio realizado a principios de los
90s identificó esta tendencia donde para
las para los niños era mucho más
probable que sus padres les compraran
consolas y computadoras que para las
niñas
alejar a las niñas de la tecnología tuvo
consecuencias más tarde cuando menos
mujeres quisieron enrolarse en carreras
stem que por sus siglas en inglés quiere
decir ciencias tecnología ingeniería y
matemáticas y las pocas que lo hicieron
empezaron desde líneas mucho más atrás
que sus compañeros hombres lo cual
aumentó la probabilidad de desmotivarse
y dejar a mitad de camino
estos paradigmas tan dañinos siguen
presentes en nuestra sociedad
en pleno 2019 sólo el 20 por ciento del
matriculado de carreras stem está
conformado por mujeres
y regresando a la historia
extraordinaria de gini vemos que ya
tampoco tuvo grandes modelos a seguir
cuando ingresó a la compañía pocas
mujeres estaban en posiciones
gerenciales y de hecho en la lista de
las empresas más importantes del mundo
no se veía ni el un nombre de una mujer
a la cabeza
allí ni se han sumado otras mujeres
stammen whitman en hewlett packard
marissa mayer en ya q pero el gap sigue
siendo gigantesco y cuando hablamos de
latinoamérica es muy evidente apenas una
de cada 100 personas que desarrollan
tecnología es mujer
y para todo esto porque creen que es
importante agregar a más mujeres en el
desarrollo de tecnología
la respuesta es que la tecnología dejó
de ser un sector o un campo de estudio
para hacer una línea transversal que
atraviesa por todo lo que hacemos por
cómo nos comunicamos y cómo trabajamos
y es por eso que es fundamental tener
una perspectiva incluyente al momento de
desarrollarla porque los usuarios ya no
solo unos pocos no somos todos sino
somos todas tener una perspectiva
incluyente en el desarrollo de productos
y servicios digitales está asegurando
también que estamos incluyendo al cien
por ciento de la población
en el pasado hemos caído en errores muy
graves por ejemplo las primeras
iteraciones de la aplicación de apple
que me di a la salud dejó totalmente
afuera los indicadores de salud
reproductiva femenina es decir que no
había indicadores de menstruación ni de
ovulación apple se dio cuenta que las
descargas de su aplicación eran muy
bajas y claramente era porque habían
dejado fuera al 50% de la población
este sesgo de género también se repitió
en el desarrollo de software
de sistemas de reconocimiento facial y
reconocimiento de voz que siguen
teniendo dificultades para interactuar
con el sexo femenino
también en el diseño de las primeras
bolsas de aire y de los cinturones de
seguridad
omitieron por completo en la anatomía
femenina y eso le costó la vida a muchas
mujeres alrededor del mundo así que no
tener una perspectiva incluyente en el
desarrollo de tecnología nos ha costado
mucho a los consumidores y a las
empresas
afortunadamente esta fotografía está
cambiando estamos avanzando hacia los
pasos correctos y eso nos da pie a que
podamos hablar sobre el potencial
si bien hoy estamos viviendo un mundo
donde la tecnología ha logrado resolver
grandes problemas ahora imaginemos qué
mundo podríamos construir si los equipos
de desarrollo colocan en el centro de la
diversidad como su gran fortaleza para
agregar valor a una humanidad que es
profundamente plural
con más mujeres desarrollando tecnología
también abrimos puertas a que más niñas
se interesen por hacerlo y que crezcan
con el ejemplo de mujeres empoderadas
líderes y haciendo lo que más les gusta
nunca más una niña tendría que limitar
su potencial por un tema de estereotipos
ahora les quiero platicar de la historia
de una mujer mexicana que está cambiando
esa fotografía su nombre es marisol
carrillo marisol siempre fue muy
inquieta por aprender a programar y por
la tecnología sin embargo creciendo en
este es en este contexto de muchos
estereotipos decidió finalmente estudiar
relaciones comerciales
desafortunadamente cuando marisol salió
de la universidad no encontró empleos
bien remunerados y eran bastante
inestables esta situación
desafortunadamente la viven 37 millones
de mujeres en latinoamérica que hoy se
encuentran sus empleadas desempleadas o
en la economía informal la promesa del
título universitario no le había puerta
no la no la habría ninguna puerta a
marisol
de hecho ella estaba desempleada cuando
fue la primera vez que escuchó del
laboratorio
le llamó mucho la atención ver un
programa que prometía enseñarle a
programar desarrollar web
y después que conseguiría un empleo en
la industria de tecnología
marisol a quien siempre los moldes que
le había puesto la sociedad le quedaron
demasiado pequeños decidió aplicar y se
quedó aprender a programar es muy
difícil
sin embargo marisol decidió no ver lo
imposible
y mejor aún decidió que era algo que
podía aprender
después de concluir el programa marisol
consiguió su primer empleo en tecnología
y a los pocos meses se fue a vivir a
washington donde se integró el equipo de
desarrollo del bid el banco
interamericano de desarrollo esta
experiencia le cambió la vida porque
para ella no solamente estaba cumpliendo
con el gran sueño de trabajar en el
extranjero sino que también había
encontrado su misión social
ella quería regresar a mexico a cambiar
su país actualmente se encuentra
trabajando el equipo de desarrollo de
una sociedad civil que se dedica a
llevar a que gobiernos y empresas rindan
cuentas y sean más transparentes ahora
el nuevo gran sueño de marisol es
convertirse en emprendedora social y
acompañar a otros niños y jóvenes que
tienen la misma inquietud por programar
hacerlo
marisol es egresada de la primera
generación de laboratorio de ciudad de
mexico ella agresso en el 2015 pero la
historia del laboratorio empieza un año
más atrás cuando con el primer piloto
graduamos a 15 mujeres en lima estas
mujeres sin ningún tipo de conocimiento
previo o experiencia en programación
después de seis meses estuvieron listas
para tener ese primer empleo que les dio
las oportunidades y la estabilidad que
necesitaban para cambiar sus vidas
desde que empezamos laboratorio tomamos
una decisión ya sea esa es la de poner
en el centro a los estudiantes y sus
necesidades siempre en todo lo que
hacemos
eso nos llevó a diseñar un programa de
clase mundial que decidimos cobrar
únicamente cuando ellas consiguen ese
empleo
cinco años después estamos en cuatro
países de latinoamérica y hay más de
1300 mujeres que ya están cambiando el
rostro de cómo se ve un equipo de
tecnología
y ahora tenemos una oportunidad mucho
más grande la de transformar a américa
latina para que se convierta en esa
economía digital ejemplo del mundo
siendo más competitiva más diversa y más
inclusiva
acompañamos a las empresas y a las
organizaciones para que puedan adquirir
estas habilidades en medio de la
transformación digital
la transformación en la era digital trae
consigo grandes oportunidades que se
abran muchísimas puertas nuestra
responsabilidad nuestra misión es que
esas puertas no se abran para unos pocos
sino que se abran para todos y para
todas
para llegar ahí tenemos que comenzar con
nosotros mismos la próxima vez que les
pregunten
porque no van a hacer algo y piensen que
es algo demasiado difícil
no digan no puedo digan aún no lo
aprendo muchas gracias